question what does abstinence
consist of where you don't
do you're not sexual at all so you're
not allowed to look at women no fab well
it's not that you can't look at women
but it was like if you if a guy if
you're looking at attractive women nine
times out of ten the first thing you
think about in the first 10 seconds is
what would it be like to have sex with
her
really is that really how what you don't
think yeah hundred percent
straight up why do you think like
manchester united
ugly now
like you know if you're in a bar or a
club if a guy approaches you it's not
because he's approaching because he
thinks you have a nice personality yeah
of course sorry
you're getting me in trouble
you called me guys
like the video
like the video we got to one point
they're really on it with the liking
today they get to one point too
one point well one thing that the lady
over there said which was very true
which is if you do ever agree to an
arranged marriage you would have your
dad
choose the man
i 100 agree because your dad would know
exactly what that man is thinking yeah
and woman will never know what a man
and how a man operates it just it's not
it's it's impossible it is impossible as
empathetic as you can be as much as you
want to sort of put yourself in another
person's shoes you will never know what
it's like to have this piece in your
brain
constantly well between your legs really
but it's
here constantly constantly it's a
constant nagging little thing that is
bugging you but also but also realize
it's that very thing that gives women
power
that's why only fans is a thing that's
why that's why instagram models is a
thing it's that exact
innate beast in them that thing that is
so difficult difficult to contend with
that gives women they pout gives women
the power they have ever made that's why
because if men didn't have it y'all
would have zero power over it over
that's why porn stars are female corn
stars get paid far more than male 1
it's the only it's one of the few
industries where the women are out earn
men easily i mean i think that's why the
laws actually favor women so much as men
gave them that power
yeah like yeah because i think female
lobbyists
yeah i think i think men have an innate
instinct to protect women yes yeah and
that's that's where i disagree with a
lot of even like conservatives is
because they never hold women
accountable even when a girl is
sleeping around it's always oh what the
man slept with her
like oh you used her for her body it's
like ah she was horny get out
a man has very few options to uh when
when a woman gets pregnant whilst a
woman has up
right and even even though it's even
though it's her choice and she made a
poor decision it's always
it's always one of the met well he
shouldn't have been sleeping with her he
shouldn't have stuck his and it's just
and it's just like well she made a
decision too no i have a i have a small
rant on this uh and that is
the the hypocrisy of this situation of
when when a man and a woman uh have you
know coitus and then the the woman turn
around go i want to keep it and then he
is in effectively indentured servitude
for the rest of for the next at least 20
years or 18 years of of that you know
child's life
and women go well you know you should
have so you are literally saying to a
man at the point where he could be drunk
or he could be just on drugs or whatever
and he's horny as crazy
that's the moment he has to make that
18-year life decision in that moment
whilst a woman has from literally date
one pregnancy to at least six months to
make her life choices she has
not
literally a buffet of birth control
options you're saying you the man who's
drunk horny and is just trying to get
his leg over that's the time you have to
make life life and death decisions
life-affirming decisions
i
i
i fully
agree with what you're saying the caveat
to that
is what i would say is this
met what does it mean to be a leader
to take responsibility for your team
and if men have historically been the
leaders
part of being the leader is you have to
hold yourself to a higher standard i'm
not saying it's fair
i'm not saying it's fair because i
completely agree if two people lie down
they both decided to but i think where
that comes from
is because men have always been seen
to lead and part of being a leader is
being responsible taking responsibility
for your tribe and your team that's why
i think where that comes from well okay
well even though she got pregnant and
she made a poor decision which is true
and nowadays because of equality yeah
you have to take accountability for that
but it's also like okay but as a man
who's supposed to become a capable
leader
he has to be take more responsibility
for the entire situation i'm not saying
it's fair but i'm saying that yeah but i
think it's just though there's a
difference between he should like if you
get a girl pregnant you should take care
of it i agree i agree but at the same
time
there's a difference between putting a
gun to a guy's head and saying pay for
it i think i should be able to have a
financial abortion yeah i agree 100
nowadays yeah of course as at least
have some parity of options the way
women have yes
with the fact that they can abort they
can
give it away for adoption women have all
of these options open to them a man
literally can't say i want this child to
be adopted the woman if she says i want
to keep it yours you're done what do
what do you guys think would you be okay
with that since we have the right to an
abortion they could get a financial
abortion where they don't have child
support
i'm fine with like a fight a
financial abortion if
i don't know if this person isn't a
stranger to you
if that's the case like you already had
an agreement or whatever maybe she's not
even a girlfriend but there's a
relationship
just sexual sure but a relationship
because that's the thing though if you
want to do a one night stand i'm sorry
you're gonna have to pay for that baby
why was that wrong
i think i think on both parts if it's a
one-night stand you're having sex with a
stranger you don't discuss let's be
honest if you're doing that so none of
you discuss um have you been tested none
of you discussed um are you going to
where are you on the pill do you even
know her to even trust that she took it
recently what does she
why does she get a reward how does she
get money that's the thing though it's
why does she get money and he doesn't
it's not necessarily a ro it's a
financial reward for her but it's not
really
a hundred thousand kids
but it's not a social reward she's a
pariah
she is not necessarily not necessarily
in today's society god forbid you want
to slut-shame her yeah and that's that's
what i'm i'm saying and most i mean
most girls will live with that for like
200k a year most girls
i'll be a piranha in my ferrari that's
right
yeah
so so why does she get a reward but
that's could you answer that question
why does she get a reward
for making a poor decision that's that's
that's the way the laws are said no i'm
saying but why
so you said you would agree with it for
a one-night stand that it should she
should get child support so since you
agreed with it why does she get a reward
for making a poor decision where men
have to pay i wouldn't consider it like
a reward necessarily because she 18
years of money
yeah i know it's a financial reward but
there are other negatives that come with
it
like if you're talking that can be
outweighed by
i know it's a fun i know but it's not
it's not really a perfect system even
for that for her i'm not saying i'm not
saying that like women who do that
should be rewarded drake's baby mama's
doing pretty well i know but again
there's no social reward for her she
wasn't she a corn star or whatever i
don't know yeah she got rewarded for a
bad decision so i'm asking you why why
do you why is it that the women
face no consequence and the men do
it's the again it's it's unusual i agree
yeah it's unfair financially and sure he
should be able to
but
if you're if you're with a stranger
if you decide to both put your pants
down together yes with a strange you
don't know how she's going to raise you
don't know what her values are you you
and she doesn't know anything about you
either
i'm sorry but you you've used basically
made a mistake both of you right he's
gonna have to pay she's gonna be a
pariah somehow whatever in some way
you know she probably won't get married
or whatever i don't know she might not
have optioned the best options that she
would have had before
now that she has a child
you know in a one-night stand situation
but if you knew each other
i would say yeah have a financial
abortion because there's some rapport
whatever so so what would you define as
new each other i don't know i don't know
like
how would legally they defer who knew
each other and who didn't
i would if even you know you know what
in a perfect world for those people
i would say maybe
some kind of evidence that it was clear
that he didn't want the child or she
didn't want a child but somehow she
changed her mind but it's there that
there was no consensus there so you
would say if they're in a relationship
no child support yeah but if it's a
one-night stand she gets child's cause
like i'm sorry you you've both you've
both tripped you both you both i'm
saying like you realize you're paying
out bad decisions even more